it's just
you know barely making it from sequence
to sequence just barely making it out of
this thing alive the gray man is full of
insane action with an incredible cast to
match it's no surprise there were a ton
of great moments filming on set we'll be
talking about improvised one-liners
highly satisfying fight scenes as well
as a few onset injuries and hilarious
moments that some people wish they could
reshoot the most straightforward
delivery of both of their lines that are
hilarious because it's just so on it
number one when theater meets film
when ryan gosling was shooting in prague
he got to enjoy having a bit of a live
audience there's a major scene where
anna dear moss's character danny saves
him from a pretty close call you'll
notice that seems to be a theme in the
movie let's go
i'm good let's go
it sounded like a question when she
leads him over to the car directly above
them are a bunch of townspeople hanging
out on their balconies drinking coffee
and watching them film i thought they
should have included them because that
was i feel like they would have been
watching this anyway number two more
like a little too much gum after looking
back at his performance there are quite
a few things ryan gosling would do
differently if given the opportunity way
too much gum
this is one of them this was supposed to
end in me blowing a bubble so i spent
the whole scene chewing this massive
piece of bubble gum they didn't even end
up using the bubble scene billy bob's
giving such a great performance i'm just
chewing chewing the scenery there's also
another funny moment where he's getting
sprayed in the face with pepper spray
okay yeah immediately as i watch this i
would react differently to the pepper
spray he thinks his reaction could have
been a little bit stronger it looks like
i'm getting sprayed with avion which is
what's happening number three or rather
getting rid of it the cast had a great
time embracing the darker more
villainous version of themselves
specifically jessica henwick and reggae
jean-page it's like taking a holiday
from the british just kind of you flush
all of the politeness out of your system
he describes it as leaning into all the
things that you would normally never do
and seeing how far that can take you i
surprised myself when i was told to yell
at chris and they said just go go as far
as you can jessica is unsure if that's
the take that was used in the final cut
but apparently she was foaming at the
mouth as the primary example of exactly
what not to do in acid retrieval
number four the hot trunk ryan gosling
was stuck in for two days this was fun
trying to figure out how this would go
down you know getting hit with a dart
like that we are definitely enjoying the
use of his word fun it led to two more
days being in a hot trunk and frog which
was not as much fun luckily though
anadare moss saving the day yet again
was taking great care of him while in
the driver's seat
apparently she's a great driver and he
felt very safe back there aside from the
sweltering heat what gives you the
impression that they care what i think
this is my career you understand number
five the incredible julia butters is
already making history she's worked with
so many legends in the industry from the
russo brothers to steven spielberg and i
said i've been wanting to work with
julia butter since i was a teenager
my favorite answer to anything ever
we're with you billy bob the improvised
moment comes into play when they are
actually on a close-up of chris julia
had already shot her close-up scene i
was about to turn and leave and i turned
back and i said kick his ass normally
she would never go off script like that
they said all right we're gonna do your
close-up again because we really liked
that and i was so excited number six and
all the reshoots that came with it oh i
wish it would have been a question the
cast spent months training for all of
the major action sequences some got the
hang of it faster than others but this
was extreme you know i think by most
action movie standards this is extreme
by most action movie standards the
number of action sequences they had to
film was pretty insane the gray man has
nine action set pieces and typical
action movies usually only have around
half of that
we gonna do this or not
number seven the man who's done 50 films
it gets to be green for a second the
actor dinosh who plays the assassin avik
san is a major player in the indian film
industry he's been working for over 22
years one thing he loved about working
on the grey man was that he got to be
the new guy again in an interview with
hindustan times he talks a little bit
about what that felt like you often
don't get the chance to feel like a
newcomer the first time it all happens
in a blur you don't realize what's
happening it's a dream role for any
actor number eight speaking of danush
let's get into ryan gosling's actual
favorite scene interestingly enough ryan
only got one scene with danush the
hospital fight which was definitely one
of the more dangerous fight sequences in
the film the hospital scene because it
almost put dinosaur in the hospital it
was a an honor to work with him though
they only got one scene together they
definitely became fast friends on screen
and off screen it's it's amazing and i i
had a great experience number nine in a
movie like this there's gotta be a few
onset injuries one particular we'd like
to take note of was on the very first
day of filming chris evans shared a
little behind the scenes mishap on his
instagram story my first day of filming
i accidentally hit ryan in the face with
the gun chris talks a bit more about it
in an interview on fandom wire there was
a scene where i had to slam him against
a wall but i'm holding a gun so as i'm
grabbing his collar you know the barrel
of the gun just kind of whacked him
right in the mouth we sympathize with
you on those first day of work jitters
chris number 10 which also doubles as a
metaphor for ryan gosling's filming
experience when talking about some of
the most difficult stunts he had to do
ryan definitely refers back to the scene
where he's running on top of a train
when all the cars are falling out
beneath him you always have to be
suspicious of what they leave for the
end of shooting we definitely don't
blame you for being suspicious
like set piece after set piece action
sequence after action sequence just
barely getting out of it unscathed ryan
actually wondered if the russo brothers
thought this was going to be the last
thing he shot ever
and in turn saved it for the very end
number 11 most definitely a highlight of
anyone's work day when chris evans got
cast for the film he was pretty
intimidated to work with ryan gosling
but overall found it to be a major
highlight of being on set very centered
person i think that's that's what's
that's the origin of why he's such a
good actor chris describes ryan as being
unbothered and sort of looked to him as
a leader throughout the film just kind
of say hey listen i got great people
around me i'm just going to let them
shine and try and not make a mess number
12 julia butters gets to push her limits
in this one one thing she really liked
about this film was finding her ability
to channel the intense emotional aspects
of herself filming the fountain sequence
was
i'm going to list that one as my number
one favorite they filmed that soaking
wet scene for a full week straight as a
young talented actor julia loves to
challenge herself i don't even think
that's real at all like sometimes i just
don't even understand what's going on
number 13 also proved to be the most
difficult the russo brothers prepped it
for about a year and it took about six
weeks to shoot the way the russo
brothers like to bring scenes like this
to life is shoot some action scenes for
a few days go into a room check out what
they shot come up with new ideas rinse
repeat something that the cast found
difficult about this was after they'd
spent two months learning this
choreography the russo brothers would
come up with something completely new to
throw in one moment in this sequence
that was actually pretty funny took
place when ryan gosling was chained to a
bench when everything was exploding and
all this action was taking place his
cell phone started to ring his wife who
was in a hotel nearby with the kids was
on the line would you respond or would
you just run i would call security yeah
no i get that that makes sense after all
of these insane action sequences
brilliant comedic moments and behind the
scenes mishaps it's hard not to be
impressed by the cast and crew of the
grey man what was your favorite part of
the film let us know in the comments and
make sure to like and subscribe to the
things